[Musique]
anachronique et roy sont les ultimes
pentes du mont-valérien que l'histoire
récente a sublimé meco l'histoire de
demain perpétuera sous les coteaux de
puteaux et courbevoie qui descendent
doucement dans la seine se donnent
rendez-vous le plus désuets ne plus
hardis le cocktail de la pierre meulière
avec l'aluminium et le verre
au soir de leur vie c'est un regard plus
inquiet que curieux que jette les
anciens à la ruée vers l'ouest du grand
paris ce grand chambardement ou les jeux
de machines leur paraissent plus
redoutable encore que les jeux de mains
du passé à torresola tournebelle
récemment la tour aquitaine trois tours
ont surgi en cinq ans autour du palais
des expositions à l'emplacement même où
la fête à neuneu chasse et voilà quatre
ans installé ses quartiers de printemps
c'est par dizaines de milliers que les
parisiens envahissait le rond-point la
défense pour aller le soir ou le
dimanche se brise et de bruits de
vitesse ils cherchaient dans les
tourbillons l'ivresse et le vertige la
griserie défaut risque des jeux bon
marché qui valait bien le retour on pas
sur quatre fils d'autostrade et qui
n'ont pas résisté et l'ass ou bien fait
de la télévision à domicile
cette fête à neuneu ce pari d'hyères que
les parisiens de 30 ans encore pu
connaître était le dernier jalon à
l'ouest de paris du grand axe
prestigieux qui des tuileries par la
concorde les champs-elysées l'étoile et
neuilly doit demain atteindre la forêt
de saint-germain-en-laye accomplissant
ainsi le rêve ébauche il ya trois
siècles par un jardinier génial le nôtre
aucune résistance ne sera plus désormais
tolérée là où l'héroïsme des soldats
fille face à l'invasion allemande la
défense emménagement la corde au cou et
déportés du monde entier on vient voir
ceux qui demain va sans doute fasciné la
france entière et bouleversé la vie de
20 millions 800 mille parisien sans que
ceux-ci sont sera jusqu'à présent le
moins du monde dotée depuis sept ans sur
100 hectares la destruction systématique
de tout ce qui existait aucun
bombardement ne m'a tomic n'aurait pu
mener à bonne fin ce qui a été entrepris
la l'anéantissement total mur après mûre
mètre après mètre le déblayage des
ruines a succédé au départ des habitants
regardez il y a dix ans presque hier le
rond-point de la défense une banlieue
paisible des petits ateliers qui
travaillent à façon pour l'automobile et
l'aviation
soudain en deux ans surgit le cnnic
le palais des grandes expositions
internationales le clip faisait la trace
comme on dit en montagne à l'une des
bases majeur de l'aménagement de notre
capitale
[Musique]
1959 la tornade elle n'existe pas encore
remontons la grande avenue qui du pont
de neuilly monte vers le rond-point de
la défense le cnit vient de s'achever
dans quelques instants nous la
survoleront de nouveau et vous jugerez
vous même alors de l'oeuvre colossal
entreprises
oh
[Musique]
soudas s'est 1975 du au delà de triomphe
au delà de l'avenue de la grande armée
de la venue de neuilly c'est la défense
paris nouveau l'édification d'un
ensemble architectural grandiose où
l'honneur des formes a été poussé aussi
loin que la permis l'alliance de la
technique et de la sociologie une ville
de 20 mille résidents ou soixante mille
personnes viendront travailler dans la
journée une station de métro digérant
cent mille personnes à l'heure une
circulation de 100000 véhicules jour
aujourd'hui 3300 francs le mètre carré
de surface utile aujourd'hui la défense
avec ses 65 mille véhicules jour détient
pour la france le record de la plus
grosse concentration de trafic
avant de construire en hauteur il
fallait donc pouvoir circuler pour ce
faire le pont de neuilly va être doublée
un premier échangeur permettra aux
voitures à l'envers courbevoie asnières
de se rendre sur leur droite sans
difficulté
[Musique]
même opération pour ceux qui veulent
aller vers plus tôt sur aisne saint
cloud sans couper deux fils
ils pourront par une série de boucles
repassé sous le pont de neuilly et
suivre les berges de la seine pour
toutes les autres destinations la sphère
était plus compliqué c'est avec un des
directeurs de l'aménagement de la
défense qu'en voiture
nous avons pris le chemin de la future
grande artère pour un voyage fantastique
où notre imagination s'essouffler
[Musique]
et monsieur nous venons de traverser le
pont de neuilly qui t'appelle à 100 m et
nous nous trouvons à peu près l'endroit
où dans quatre ou cinq ans c'est un
hobby liste rentreront sous un grand
tunnel
en effet les parisiens par exemple qui
aurait décidé d'aller en province à la
porte maillot ou le périphérique se
penchera sur l'autoroute a14 entreront
au sous ce souterrain dans le quartier
de défense et continueront tout droit
sans aucun peut ni cisaillement
passeront de part et d'autre de la
station du réseau express régional de la
dépense et émergeront à l'air libre de
l'autre côté des voies sncf pour monter
sur un remblai qui dominera la plaine de
lanternes quinzaine de mètres en feront
ils se dirigeront ensuite vers saint
germain et orgeval toutes les personnes
habitant le nord nord ouest de paris
l'apport de chaque d'autres et pourquoi
séparer alors à l'intérieur ce n'est
sous exactement l'ancien encan la
défense va se trouver un échange un
échange et a donc vous dites le premier
du monde souterrain
et en plus ces cinq niveaux pourquoi
cinq niveaux c'est en effet le premier
échangeur souterrain monde il ya un loup
qui franchira fiction à l'air libre en
général et il ya cinq niveaux car il
faut assurer les circulations et dans
toutes les directions notamment vers les
voies qui s'en vont ou qui reviennent de
la garenne maisons laffitte et maisons
et d'un autre côté pour les voies qui
vont ou qui reviennent de saint germain
et deux revers pour éviter toutes deux
conflits entre des voitures allant vers
la province tout en redonnant et ses
différentes directions dont je vais
parler il est nécessaire de faire des
tourne à droite il prend la gauche qui
explique que l'échangeur à 5 libre une
question que tout le monde se pose est
que je me pose en particulier c'est
comment circuler dans cette ville future
est par exemple comment se rendre en
taxi
ce particulier attend de nous c'est
nombreuses tours que nous verrons plus
tard istres a pour les voitures
particulières devront stationner dans le
secteur elles emprunteront le
périphérique qui est sur notre droite
ici et par une série de petites voix
particulière entreront dans les cellules
de parquet
par contre il ya une voie spéciale que
nous avons créée qui est branché sur le
périphérique tout près d'ici et
d'ailleurs qui suit en gros la kz du
quartier et permet par une série de
piquage d'immerger les sous sol des
bâtiments soit à usage de bureaux chaude
à usage de commerce soit les habitations
parce cette loi spéciale cette voie de
desserte locale passe les camions les
taxis donne accès au parking central
immédiatement sous la halle centrale est
également les autobus et le gabarit à
dire été calculée pour recevoir des
véhicules lourds et en particulier les
autobus avec leurs petits drapeaux des
jours de fête
[Musique]
un problème humain douloureux a
forcément marqué la réalisation de ces
sites en australie
le départ de ceux qui occupaient
paisiblement ou laborieusement signé
4000 familles et 300 petites entreprises
en liaison permanente avec
l'administration les collectivités
locales
l'organisme public chargé d'aménager la
défense a trouvé là aussi une solution
originale qui fera jurisprudence
un principe reloger tout le monde à
proximité immédiate de la nouvelle zone
non
pour locataires expulsés des hlm ont été
construits à puteaux et nanterre
ils s'inscrivent harmonieusement dans le
style de la défense ils sont déjà
occupés pour les propriétaires
n'acceptant pas d'indemnités un
appartement dans un grand ensemble se
dresse face au cnit
[Musique]
pour les artisans et les petites
entreprises qui travaillaient dans des
locaux vétustes et délabrées un complexe
industriel d'un genre unique fut édifiée
où chacun a pu retrouver la même surface
au sein d'une collectivité qui lui
permet de profiter en commun des
commodités social cantine par exemple
auparavant au dessus de leurs moyens
[Musique]
en
nous sommes maintenant juste en dessous
la turakie thème qui est à peine
terminée les 65000 personnes qui passent
tous les jours visible sur les allées
mais se posent des questions et se
demandent pourquoi le tout en à ça à la
base à une forme aussi bizarre bien
c'est justement ce que l'audition tout à
l'heure les niveaux que vous voyez sans
fenêtre au pied de la tour des pétroles
d'aquitaine seront des niveaux de sous
sols le réchauffé affectés aux piétons
de la ville future sera au niveau à
partir duquel nous commencions à voir
les ouvertures dans les structures
l'ampleur de ces travaux
révolutionnaires
cette projection de la technique dans le
monde demain a été confié à une équipe
d'hommes qui au service de l'état de la
ville de paris des collectivités locales
montrent que leurs oeuvres n'est pas le
fruit sorti de l'imagination délirante
de technocrates distinguer c'est une
oeuvre collective une entreprise
nationale à ne pas confondre avec la
promotion immobilière commerciale aussi
grande que la première zone bleue la
zone de la défense qui est une force de
dissuasion légale au quartier
saint-lazare et qui doit décongestionner
paris en favorisant son expansion
à la tête de cette équipe un homme
monsieur protin qui déteste être
comparée à ce mal un ingénieur en chef
inconnu du grand public qui tout au long
de sa carrière a construit des ponts des
souterrains des ouvrages d'art que nous
utilisons machinalement tous les jours à
paris qui n'hésite pas vous l'avez vu à
être partout sur son chantier pour mieux
parler de l'oeuvre à laquelle il se
consacre désormais passionnés
il y aura là effectivement en surface
sur cette dalle dont on vous a déjà
parlé et qui supportera quelque 30
hectares de jardin on y trouvera des
bureaux environ 800 mille mètres carrés
de bureaux qui seront répartis dans ses
tours chacune de ces tours ayant une
centaine de mètres de hauteur
on y trouvera des milliers de logements
dans des bâtiments beaucoup plus bas
qu'ils n'auront que quatre niveaux les
voici combien mille logements 7 milles
environ et on y trouvera des magasins
des boutiques abrités dans des bâtiments
encore beaucoup plus bas je vous en
montre ici en face du cnit sur le parvis
de cette ville qui va s'offrir aux
visiteurs un peu à la manière d'une
ville à flanc de coteau en partant des
coteaux de la défense et en descendant
sur la scène
monsieur protin qu'est ce qui
différencie qu'est ce qui distingue ce
projet cette maquette de ce qui existe à
l'heure actuelle en france qu en europe
dans le monde a tout d'abord les 30
hectares de jardin parce que ça c'est
assez inhabituel 30 hectares de jardins
à la disposition de cette population et
des jardins qui vous le savez ne sont
pas traversé par les voitures puisque
toute la circulation se fait en dessous
donc pas de bruit pas de danger et pas
d'odeur pas de gaz de voitures l'accès à
ces différents bâtiments se fera
exclusivement comme vous le savez
également par les sous sols les 20000
places de stationnement on y accédera en
par la voie périphérique qui fait le
tour et on arrivera au pied de chacun
des immeubles en pouvant laisser sa
voiture dans un rayon maximal de 150
mètres du pied de l'immeuble
en dehors de cela nous recherchons
évidemment
dès la création l'établissement de
quartier aussi individualisée possible
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de ses
surfaces de commerces et nous pensons
bien qu'il y aura là notamment du côté
du parvis par loin du cnit probablement
un ou deux grands magasins nous
l'espérons nous pensons qu'on y trouvera
aussi des supermarchés des magasins
populaires et des boutiques ces petites
boutiques de détaillants qui font la vie
des quartiers parisiens et qui la
faisait peut-être même encore plus
autrefois et alors nous souhaitons qu'il
y ait et quelques quartiers très
différents les uns des autres nous
verrions parfaitement le quartier des
libraires le quartier des grands
restaurants le quartier pourquoi pas des
petits bistrots des petits cafés
il y aura des salles de spectacles de
cinéma des foyers des salles de culture
il y aura une piscine
il y aura des salles de culture physique
de petits terrains de sport nous
voudrions que cette ville et sa vie
propre qu'elle vive qu'elle vive
ardemment intensément que notamment on y
lit et de l'animation aussi bien le
matin que le soir aussi bien en semaine
que le dimanche
et pourquoi pas même un peu la nuit et
nous soignons tout particulièrement les
éclairages
je crois que dans l'esprit des
architectes qui ont construit l'ensemble
cette maquette il y a une orientation
générale de tous les bâtiments si bien
le oui le magasin ceci aussi est un est
une caractéristique je crois qui sera
particulière à ce quartier on le voit
très bien sur ce plan vous voyez le
soleil se lève à l'est bien entendu et
se couche à l'ouest voilà donc le trajet
qu'il fait et vous remarquerez que ces
rayons vont pouvoir pénétrer très avant
à l'intérieur de tous ces bâtiments qui
ont été disposés pour cela
la défense n'aurait pas atteint la
perfection qu'on a recherché pour elle
si elle n'avait pas fourni à la ville
toute entière la climatisation qui
s'imposera demain dans notre vie
quotidienne
ainsi a été construite elle marche au
gaz de l'apli au charbon la plus grande
usine thermique du monde par l'échelle
et la quantité d'immeubles desservant
tout ceci aurait été évidemment
impossible à réaliser sans une
rénovation absolue du sous sol mais
aussi dans cette technique du 21e siècle
ce qu'on appelle dans la future vie de
la défense une galerie technique
oui c'est un peu la ddt la hauteur du
métropolitain enfin oui un peu trois
enfants c'est un ouvrage dans ses
grandes dimensions eau potable eaux
industrielles voirie pompiers commerce
aux glaces et 5 degrés aux chaudes 180
degrés ces conduites sont destinés à la
climatisation des immeubles qui seront
construites dans la zone de la défense
parce que tous les immeubles commerces
bureaux logements seront climatisés air
chaud et rieur fois ce sera une ville un
peu près 100 saison elle s'arrêtera la
même température totanes exactement mais
en dessous nous vous avez lisent les
égouts pour les eaux usées et les eaux
pluviales et sous la dalle du sol vous
avez un blog ptt dans lequel passent des
câbles téléphoniques et là dans quelques
semaines
le dr julien va passer quatre câbles de
20 kg vol
voilà ici au niveau du plafond ces
câbles sont destinés à l'alimentation de
des immeubles qui seront dans la zone de
la défense ultime étape de cette visite
la station de métro au coeur et plaque
tournante de la nouvelle ville monsieur
nous voici devant une maquette d'un
ouvrage d'art complexe énorme qui a été
construit à à peu près deux ans et demi
voyez les gens qui visitait le cnit le
palais des expositions on avait vu sept
trous absolument énorme qui était devant
le paradou dans le l'entrée du clip
cette maquette est ce qu'on peut nous a
commenté
eh bien oui ce trou qui avait 250 mètres
de long 70 à 80 m de large et 25 20 à 25
mètres de profondeur a reçu un ouvrage
complexe qui comprend cinq niveaux
en partant du bas le premier niveau et
le niveau des quais le deuxième niveau
est un niveau des changes d'un niveau
technique mais le partido de ce niveau
parce les deux branches de l'autoroute
paris province et province paris puis un
troisième niveau qui est le niveau le
plus important les changes public que
nous appelons la salle des pas perdus
qui est une grande salle aux proportions
architectural assez remarquable je pense
enfin nous arrivons à un quatrième
niveau qui est un niveau en espèces de
balcon au-dessus de la salle des pas
perdus et où passeront et où
stationneront les taxis et les autobus
enfin le toit de cet ouvrage qui est le
rez-de-chaussée de la future ville
un cinquième niveau qui est le parvis
actuellement en cours de recouvrement
nous voici monsieur haut niveau le plus
bas de ce grand complexe souterrain de
la défense vous appelez se croit le
niveau numéro un c'est le niveau numéro
1 le niveau des quais vous avez quatre
quais de quais latéraux et deux caisses
entreront les quais auront environ 200
mètres de long et seront susceptibles de
recevoir du cinquante mille voyageurs à
l'heure dans chaque sens c'est-à-dire
saint germes à paris et paris
saint-germain non en impression que les
travaux sont déjà très avancés puisque
des ouvriers s'affairent de tous les
côtés mais exact mais le rôdeur est
maintenant terminée
la ratp procèdent au second oeuvre la
décoration fait des essais de revêtement
en plastique sur les photos les essais
d'éclairage et dans le fond de la
station des pauses actuellement les
batteries d'escaliers mécaniques et
enfin vous voici à la porte d'une des
deux rames du futur métro express une
rame grandeur nature mais qui n'est
qu'une maquette c'est une maquette qui a
été fait pour juger des effets
d'éclairage pour les voyageurs sortant
de la ramée sortant sur les quais ou
venant des quais entrant dans les rames
de métro on pense déjà au futur confort
des voyageurs et bien sûr alors les
voyageurs qui descendront comme vous
voulez être en ce moment de ce métro
auront le choix entre plusieurs sorties
eh bien ils vont d'abord immédiatement
passé au niveau au dessus que nous
allons aller voir si vous voulez bien
par des batteries d'escaliers mécaniques
huit batteries qui les amène au niveau
numéro 2
le niveau d'eau un niveau un peu bâtard
monsieur oui c'est un niveau qui n'est
pas très spectaculaire
c'est surtout au niveau technique au
fond qui permet le retournement des
escaliers mécaniques depuis le niveau
des quais jusque au niveau de la salle
des pas perdus que nous verrons tout à
l'heure c'est également un niveau où se
trouveront les différents guichets
locaux techniques de la ratp mais il a
ceci de remarquable c'est que de part et
d'autre se trouvent les deux branches de
l'autoroute province-paris et
paris-province
on aussi nous voici donc pas encore à
l'air libre mais presque au niveau 3
cette grande grande grande salle oui
vous voulez que cette salle aux
dimensions très imposante et d'un petit
peu le coeur de cette station
ce complexe tard que représente la
station rer de la défense
c'est un petit peu la salle des pas
perdus de la gare saint-lazare si vous
voulez on voit très bien les amoureux
veulent en se donner rendez vous au pied
d'une grande horloge qui pourrait être
la lutte rames modernes bien sûr c'est
également à l'endroit que choisir à
l'arrière ratp pour faire une galerie
marchande vraisemblement à ce niveau
cette salle des pas perdus un drugstore
un gendre store je pense à jean le
boxster avec quelques bouddhique
présentant des objets de paris de luxe
que les étrangers fréquenteront
vraisemblablement c'est une grande
salade échange du côté de l'ouest des
échanges seront possibles avec la gare
sncf en cours de construction
du côté de l'est vers paris il y aura un
couloir de communication et des changes
avec la station des autobus de la ratp
du côté du nord un accès direct dans les
niveaux inférieurs du palais des
expositions du clip et de ce côté ci le
côté sud
un accès direct vers l'est
les installations commerciales que nous
prévoyons d'autres secteurs et également
vers le parvis qui sera au pied de la
grande tour de le 100 m situé en face du
clic niveau 4 nous sommes pour l'instant
encore à l'air libre mais je crois plus
tard tous seront enterrés oui ce niveau
sera également sous dalle bien sûr il
est une espèce de mezzanine de balcon si
vous voulez au dessus de la salle des
pas perdus que nous avons vu tout à
l'heure et que l'on peut pas recevoir
d'ici et qu'on peut apercevoir d'ici
c'est un niveau où nous retrouvons la
voiture soit sous forme de taxi par
exemple qui seront stationnés ici et
c'est également ici que passera à une
ligne d'autobus qui fera une sorte de la
bête et recueillera également le même
genre de client est alors un petit peu
au dessus nous apercevons le toit du
cnit voisine la dernière branche de la
patrie d'escaliers mécaniques qui
amèneront les gens du niveau des quais
de la station enfin du métro et rer au
ciel libre devant le parvis du canal
bien allons-y
c'est au terme de ce petit voyage que
nous amener du niveau 1 là bas en bas
loin en dessous le quai du métro
et voici à l'air libre au ciel eh bien
je sommes effectivement sur le plafond
de cet ouvrage d'art complet ce que nous
avons déjà visité dont les quais je vous
rappelle sont à 20 mètres au-dessous du
seuil actuel et le solde également au
rez-de-chaussée de la future ville au
pied du cnit également alors le dessus
de cette partie comme vous l'appelez
sera comment rennes y aura un tel âge
avec des dessins qui ont été mises au
point pendant de longs mois d'études en
marbre qui sera certainement digne à la
fois du quartier du palais des
expositions et de cet urbanisme nouveau
que nous voulons réaliser mes passagers
sortent en soit la salle des pas perdus
soit du métro soit de la sncf
en débouchant ici auront cette vue assez
remarquable sur paris d'abord bien
entendu sur la droite la tour eiffel à
gauche le sacré coeur
tout ceci est environné de l'ultra
moderne qui jailliront de la dalle et
les jardins et enfin dans laxe le lac
noble de paris l'arc de triomphe que
vous voyez maintenant les guides vont
épaissir les cars de touristes augmenter
leurs circuits comme la colline de
chaillot la plaine de villiers la plaine
des sablons la défense nouveau pôle
d'attraction sera elle aussi débordés
déjà à l'arrière on commence à songer à
l'après demain et ce qui est en cours
vient compléter avant leers qui sera
vingt mille étudiants à la faculté des
lettres droit et sciences politiques de
nanterre déjà ouverte depuis deux ans
devant elle un ensemble sportif
universitaire avec une piscine olympique
salfit stade omnisport inauguration
novembre prochain posée il ya quelques
jours une future ruche
la première pierre de la préfecture des
hauts-de-seine partiellement terminé
dans les prochaines et l'ensemble voulue
par monsieur malraux le musée du 20e
siècle et les quatre écoles d'art la
défense dépassée par les évènements
attend d'être fixé sur son destin un
destin qui est le nôtre aussi
et qui nous rappellerait s'il le fallait
que depuis les pyramides
il n'y a pas de gigantisme sans le
travail de deuil
[Musique]